[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
bigquery ml can enable you to build
machine learning models quickly
bigquery ml lets you operationalize
machine learning models right within
bigquery using standard sql
ml usually requires extensive
programming and knowledge of specialized
frameworks
but bigquery ml empowers you to use your
existing sql skills
to build and use machine learning models
in under 10 minutes saving you from
exporting data
and managing ml infrastructure it
supports running models on
petabyte-scale data
in a fraction of the time it can also
handle pre-processing like splitting
data
one-hot encoding and normalization and
it comes with support for many types of
ml models
and so much more you can even use auto
ml tables to create best-in-class models
while handling feature engineering and
model selection
to set up bigquery ml create the data
set in bigquery and just write a simple
sql query with the create model clause
to create the model
execute the query to run and observe the
model as it's being trained in the model
stats tab
from there you can use your trained
model to make predictions using the
mlpredict function in a new query
and enjoy the results directly in the
bigquery console just like that
bigquery ml democratizes predictive
analytics and makes it easier for anyone
to get started with ml
it's being used for anomaly detection
customer segmentation
product recommendations predictive
forecasting and more
so next time you want to build models
using your bigquery data
take a minute to look at bigquery ml to
learn more check out cloud.google.com
[Music]
bigquery-ml
you